hello my name is thomas dietrich and i'm
a professor emeritus at oregon state
university uh and my
research career has been devoted to
machine learning in various different
many different uh applications and
theoretical settings and today i'm
very honored to have the chance to talk
to you about anomaly detection and some
of the work that i and other people have
been doing in this in this area
uh i want to start out by thanking uh
dan hendricks who was an intern with me
and bilaji lakshman ryan who is at
google and was a
master's student at oregon state
uh for their advice and suggestions in
putting together this presentation
so uh my motivation for studying uh
anomaly detection and related techniques
was a project i was doing about 20 years
ago
that involved the automated counting of
freshwater macro invertebrates so
macroinvertebrates just means large bugs
that live in freshwater streams and the
u.s environmental protection agency
every year does a randomized sampling of
freshwater streams and rivers in the
united states
to assess their
health
and uh this is done by taking what's
called a kick net which you can see here
on the right uh and you basically kick
the
the the sort of stuff on the bottom of
the stream into the net and you're
capturing these
insects that live most of their lives as
in a larval stage underwater they have
gills and so on
they only come out of the water to mate
at the very end of their lives and uh
and so the idea that the the
the challenge with this from an
application point of view is that uh
they collect these samples and then
someone has to uh identify them down to
at least the genus level and ideally to
the species level
and that requires very specialized
expertise and it's very time consuming
and so we had the thought well could we
make a
robotic apparatus that you could take
the sample dump it in it would
separate out each insect
photograph it under standardized
conditions and then we would use
computer vision to identify it
and uh this was in the pre-deep learning
days
we uh our our collaborators collected
100 specimens of each of 54 classes so
not a huge data set by any means
and our classifier was getting something
like 90 percent accuracy and you can see
will be published at uh cbpr and so on
um and so uh we i was quite happy with
this
until we realized that well actually
there are going to be other things in
our fields samples besides these 54
classes of insects in fact there are 76
000 species of freshwater insects
worldwide and there are 1200 species in
the united states
and beyond bugs the field samples
because they're being processed by a
robotic system
might also contain small rocks or leaves
or bits of plastic things like this
and so we did a just a simple estimate
of equal error rate just based on
insects leaving out some of the insects
and found that our equal error rate was
something like 20 percent so we were
failing to identify 20 percent of of
species that did belong to our 54 and we
were um uh also uh falsely classifying
other stuff we call them the aliens
as belonging 20 of them as belonging to
our 54 classes
so this is known of course as the open
category problem with the open set
problem that when you take a classifier
and apply it in the wild you may
encounter classes of
objects or whatever
that you did not see during training
uh and so
the this opera arises in any application
like novel obstacles encountered by a
self-driving car
as we saw with the
sweden's uh
volvo uh
self-driving cars when they tested them
in australia
had not been trained on kangaroos and
were surprised by them novel diseases in
medical imaging novel products in online
marketplaces and novel cyber attacks at
pretty much everywhere
and so the the the claim that i that i
want to make is that every deployed
machine learning classifier should
include a competence model
that uh that captures somehow the domain
of competence or or region of competence
of the classifier
and
the
that
so then the question is well how to
build such a thing and the strategy that
we've been pursuing
uh in the research community is
primarily to think of this as an anomaly
detection problem does this new query
which i'll call xq here in this diagram
does this uh look like it is a a query
that the classifier which is down here
is competent to to classify and so we're
going to get some sort of a competent
score or an anomaly score and if the
confidence score is high enough or uh or
the anomaly score is low
then we want to reject this uh this case
in our case with the robot we wanted it
to to send the uh the problematic
uh specimens into a separate bin for the
human expert to handle
but if the classifier is competent
enough then we can go ahead and just run
the classifier so this is a version of
classification with the rejection option
with the reject option here is due to it
being an anomaly
now in some applications you can you
also don't you don't need to
process single queries at a time you
could batch them up and look at the
batch statistics and then it becomes
more of a change detection problem to
detect that there there's a different
distribution in this data set than you
were trained on
but i won't be discussing exchange
detection any further here today
okay so
how do we define anomaly detection
formally um in the literature people
kind of uh there's been a lack of
precision um and the definition that we
have uh settled on is that an anomaly is
a data point that was generated by a
process that is different than the
process that's generating the nominal
data so we'll talk about nominal
nominals being the known uh categories
of objects and anomalies uh or aliens
being the the new by categories
so we're going to look at two uh setups
one is where the tr we've given
unlabeled data in both cases so we're
given capital n unlabeled training
examples
and in the first case uh all the data
come from the nominal distribution which
we'll call d naught
and so this is the clean data case in
the second case the data come from a
mixture of the nominal and the anomaly
distributions
and so we have contaminated training
data
and this is uh typically happens for
instance in
financial fraud detection or cyber
security where you you just cannot be
sure that you have a clean data set but
hopefully
the um
the frequency of anomalies is small
in and so we'll call the anomaly
distribution da
and then we're going to be given test
data
from a mixture of the two distributions
and our goal is to find the data points
in the test data that belong to the
anomaly distribution
of course we might also want to use this
to clean
the the training data and that would be
a separate application
now one uh important note is that uh in
some applications or deployments the
anomalies are not coming from a
stationary distribution so if we think
about uh cyber security or financial
fraud um that we're we have an adversary
and they will be adapting and so
it would be a mistake to assume that the
anomalies come from a stationary
distribution
uh we we will assume uh that the the
nominal distribution is stationary
and that suffers from all the the
problems in general in machine learning
that that
that after deployment we will need to
adapt to to changing distributions
even over our known classes
okay so in the literature there are two
problem formulations one is known as the
ood problem and the other the open
category problem
and uh the the main difference is in the
evaluation methodology because the setup
is basically the same we assume that
we're given n training examples from d
naught they belong to one of k classes
and the testing data is a mixture d m
of the d naught and the d a so the
nominals and the anomalies
but uh but but in the in this setup the
anomalous points are coming from a
different data set
so uh
whereas in the open category case
what we usually do is we're going to set
aside out of the total k classes we
might train on a subset of them and use
the remaining classes to be the uh to
stand in for our novel classes our alien
categories
um and then and uh the rest of it is the
same given a query xq we want to decide
really just make the boolean decision
does it belong to d a or d naught and if
it's from d a then we want to reject it
else we want to classify it
and so
as i say the difference is the
evaluation protocol so the typical setup
for out of distribution is we train on
data from domain a and we test from a
mix of a and b and so we might train on
mnist and test on a mix of mnist and
fashion mnist
whereas in the open category or novel
category setting we will will hold out
say the digits 6 through 0 and we'll
just train on digits 1 through 5 and
then test on all 10 digits
okay well what metrics do we use to
evaluate these well the typical one is
the area under the roc curve for this
binary decision
and of course
this is a favorite in machine learning
but perhaps not as relevant to this
problem to this kind of problem uh as
other metrics
so other ones that people looked at is
looking at the correct detection rate at
a fixed false alarm rate so if you have
a problem with false alarms that is
false to get false
claims that it's an alien
that those are very expensive then what
you want to do is control your false
alarm rate and then maximize your true
positive rate maximize your detection of
these aliens subject to that constraint
conversely in a kind of ai safety type
applications like a self-driving car or
something
we're more concerned about the missed
alarm rate so we want to
ensure that say we're getting a 95
percent true positive rate and only
missing five percent of the aliens uh
and then subject to that we want to
minimize our false alarm rate
okay well uh in it's my view that the
out of distribution detection setting is
usually easier than the novel category
setting because when you pull data from
a different data set uh there may be
very simple global image statistics that
can tell you which data set the data
point came from
and uh so so uh whereas in the novel
novel category protocol
uh the data have typically all been
collected by the same methods and
involved very similar objects so they
aren't cues from lighting or object size
or viewpoint things like this
that
can can give you
an
uh unrealistic advantage
um i also don't think that the
out-of-distribution case corresponds to
a real world case
if you train on mnist for postal code
recognition you aren't likely to
suddenly be given fashion mnist images
but uh but obviously there are
situations where the lighting the camera
and so on have changed from your
training data um
and and this this could be like in the o
od s but the o d case is easier to study
because you can download someone's
pre-trained network and apply your
technique on top of it and evaluate and
so it's been i'd say much more popular
in the research literature but i think
the novel category case of course at
least for my real world use case is the
one i care about
so in the remainder of this presentation
what i want to do is first review the
main i guess theoretical approaches to
anomaly detection and give a little
explanation of each so that will have a
bit of a tutorial flavor to it
and then i want to try to review recent
research on deep anomaly detection
and talk about the struggles that we're
having trying to get anomaly detection
to work in deep learning things
and then i finally wrap up with some
work out of my own group on how to set
the anomaly detection threshold for that
last case where we want to
try to control
the missed alarm rate and make it as
small as possible how do we set our
threshold to achieve that when we don't
have any label training data for the
anomaly
well there are basically four uh
theoretical methods uh
approaches that i think uh
cover most of the literature
i think absolutely fundamental is the
idea that we need some representation in
which we can measure distances
and so a classic thing that's been used
in featurized data sets is to just say
let's take the uh the
distance from the query to the
nearest neighbor in the training data or
the nearest k neighbors or something
like this right and that can give us our
anomaly score
on top of that we could layer density
estimation methods but density
estimation still basically assumes that
underlying it there is some
notion of neighborhoods and nearness but
then we can use perhaps a better uh
signal which is the the surprisal
right which is the minus log probability
the idea being that if something has a
very low probability then its negative
log will be very high so we and we will
be infinitely surprised if something of
probability zero is observed
uh whereas if something has probability
one we'll have a surprisal of zero
and so this leads us to wanting to model
the joint distribution of the input
space
some people have criticized the density
estimation approach of saying well
you're you're having to solve a more
difficult problem than you need to solve
and maybe we should listen to vladimir
vapnik who says don't do that uh think
about the the precisely problem you need
to solve which might be to find a
a decision boundary around your training
data that contains one minus alpha of
the training data and then use your
anomaly score to be essentially your
distance from that decision boundary uh
outside of it
and then so all three of those are
basically trying to get a grasp on how
similar the input data point is to the
training data and measuring that by some
notion of distance and density
the the fourth technique is
quite different i think the goal here
is uh is to try to
set up a problem in which the the
machine learning system will fail when
it's given new data points
in particular
uh typically we train some kind of an
auto encoder to reconstruct the input
given given the input right so we we
learn an encoder and a decoder and given
x we encode it into typically a
bottleneck of course but has some kind
of representational constraints then
decode it back to try to get the
original image back and we want to do
this in such a way that on
queries that belong to outside of the
training data there will be a high
reconstruction error so that it's not
competent to reconstruct those points
and we use our reconstruction
okay well just to go into these a little
bit more
um let's think about the the sort of
requirements for each one so if we're
going to use distance based message
methods we need a good distance metric
and this means also that we're assuming
that all all of the input dimensions are
are equally relevant
and of course we might explore weighted
distance metrics and so on but we have
to keep in mind we have no supervised
data for training those metrics uh so
doing feature selection and metric
learning is is quite a challenge with uh
for distance based methods
for density estimation we have this
challenge of of doing density estimation
potentially in a high dimensional space
and we know that that's quite
challenging
um and and i wanted to do a particular
dive here on a deep density estimation
because uh many of us got very excited
when
these ideas of
autoregressive flows were first
developed as a way of doing deep density
estimation because of course
almost all machine learning problems
could be solved if we could achieve deep
density estimation and conditional
density estimation
so um for those of you who haven't seen
these techniques the idea is to
transform some known distribution for
example a multivariate gaussian
into a target distribution that has high
likelihood on our training data
so typically we would we would start
with some uh multivariate gaussian here
and then push it through
a chain of functions
uh such that um
coming out of this these transformed
values
are distributed according to uh the
target probability distribution and
obviously we have a sample from that
distribution and we want to maximize the
likelihood of the data
for that sample and we'll call the whole
function capital f here and say that
it's parameterized by theta
now uh
we would like f to be invertible
because then the idea is that uh to to
compute the uh given a query xq to
compute its density we can run f
backwards and measure its density under
the gaussian here
and and that that will be very easy
thing to do
and of course the constraint is that we
must preserve the probabilities of
events um
so uh if we if we if we have a a
probability density uh p of x um
an event is going to be a region and
this probability mass will be you know
integrating that that density that
measure over that region
and so we need to ensure that any region
in the input space the corresponding
integral in z space at least maybe for
small regions
is gives the same answer
um and one way to achieve that is with
the change of variables formula
so uh we if if we uh uh
calculate the determinant of the
jacobian of of f inverse uh and and use
that to multiply the gaussian by this
then uh then then we we will know that
the resulting function is a density uh
and this compensates for any stretching
or compression of the space at least at
point wise
okay so um the main techniques that have
been used for constructing deep density
models are to is to ensure that each a
little f in that chain
is invertible and has an easy to compute
jacobian
and just as an example
masked auto-aggressive flow or math by
papa markarios and colleagues that came
out in 2017
uses uh basically an auto aggressive
function right so it uh if we're talking
about images it builds a
function of the first pixel and then a
function that predicts the second pixel
given the first and the third pixel
given the first and the second and so on
so a sort of triangular shape
which is what the masking refers to
and uh and they give this example um
where they want where the true density
looks like this
and they fit a mass auto regressive flow
that has a certain number of layers in
it um and they didn't get a very good
fit
and the distribution of the z values was
clearly not gaussian so then they stack
several of these networks together
so this is a stack of five ma mafs and
you can see that now they've got a very
good fit between the true density and
this fitted density and the the z values
that are coming out of f inverse
are uh
very nicely uh
two dimensional gaussian
and they have experiments showing that
comparing a few against real mvp which
is another very nice method
and showing that uh they were generally
getting better hold out
uh log likelihoods
um
now there was an important paper i think
last year at icml by priyank kobrasev
you and brubaker and they they uh proved
that if you're using a gaussian as your
source distribution then you are
restricted in the kinds of tails you can
fit so you can't fit arbitrary
probability distributions only ones that
have uh basically uh exponential tails
so if you're fitting to something that
has heavier tails they suggest that you
might want to use a student t
distribution as your source distribution
that you transform
okay but then i think a very insightful
paper was published uh late last year uh
by leilani and din
uh uh with the title perfect density
models cannot guarantee anomaly
detection
uh and uh and and uh
here's a kind of my translation of their
argument they make many good points in
the paper and i i recommend it very
highly
but um you know we want to use minus log
p as our anomaly score and we usually
use just the density we plug in the
density here rather than computing an
event whereas strictly speaking
surprisal only applies to probability
mass
and uh
and of course
a single point and the density has zero
mass
so a solution of course would be to
consider a region surrounding our query
uh say a ball of radius rho
and and then we would want to know the
probability that x belongs to that ball
and we could do that by integrating the
density obviously
so when we're using the density instead
of the event
we're basically assuming that the
density x is a good approximation of the
of the event
and basically sort of a piecewise flat
assumption
but it turns out this assumption is
broken in most of these deep density
models because the invertible flow that
we create between the initial
distribution and and our
output uh warps the space changes the
distance between points
so that the local density can be very
different uh in the transform space than
it is back in our original multivariate
gaussian
and so uh uh
and so this is the key thing that that
the very thing that gives us power which
is this ability to create this very
distorted um transformed space
is distorting and transforming uh a
sensible neighborhood in the
multivariate gaussian into some very
strangely shaped thing i just drew this
by hand but you can imagine it's been
stretched and twisted and so on um
in an invertible way but still could be
a very complex
transformation and so uh uh you know
since density is really um
we want to use it for anomaly detection
to detect a region of the space that is
that has very few data points in it
unfortunately after transformation uh
that may that may not correspond to a
nice compact region
um
and so uh so this may explain why people
have not had very good luck trying to do
uh
use deep density estimation for anomaly
detection
so i think the lesson is that the
representational space matters the
distance function that we are that we're
getting in that space is critically
important you really can't do density
estimation without assuming some notion
of distance
so we really want to do our density
estimation in a meaningful space and
when we think about it actually doing it
in the pixel space of the original
images doesn't make any sense at all we
know that's not the semantically
interesting space um
and and of course we want to avoid
having to do integrations uh
so we want to learn a good latent space
in which images of similar contents are
close together and so the distance is
sensible there and then
perhaps doing deep density estimation in
that space would make sense and people
have had success
with that approach
okay so the third approach uh back to
the main narrative is quantile methods
and again the famous techniques here are
the one class support vector machine or
support vector data description which
draw a boundary around say 99 of the
data points
and there are deep extensions of this
lucas ruff's phd dissertation was about
deep svdd
in our experience this method is
somewhat tricky to work with um because
the idea is that you're going to
transform your input space into a space
where you'll be able to draw a
hypersphere around say 95 percent of the
data points
but if you're not careful it just maps
everything to the origin and then it's
of course really easy to draw a
hypersphere around it but really
meaningless also
so they have a couple of tricks uh they
initialize their their neural network
that's going to trans do this
transformation and then um push all the
points through it and calculate the mean
of those points in the latent space
before doing any learning at all and
they constrain the hypersphere to be
there and they also have shown that they
need to have no bias weights in in this
network
because that's another source of
collapse
okay well the last uh the last main
method right that i that i was
mentioning before is reconstruction
methods
and i want to take us back now 23 years
to uh when dean pomerleau was a phd
student at cmu and they were working on
the first self-driving or at least a
self-steering lane keeping
car which was a van
that had to
be big enough to carry a bunch of big
workstations in the back
uh and they were using a neural network
with this structure
there was a uh four looking camera that
produced a 30 by 32 pixel uh image
that went down to four hidden units and
then up to 30 hidden units that were
encoding the steering angle to be used
and then also from those same four
hidden units there was a decoder that
was seeking to reconstruct the original
image
basically this was an auto encoder
through a very tight bottleneck of four
hidden units
and uh and what they did was
continuously monitor the reconstruction
error and if the reconstruction error
dropped then they would not trust the
steering
output
and uh and the argument was well
they're both the steering and the
reconstruction are using the same four
hidden unit values
and so if one is bad the other is
probably bad too but of course the
beauty of reconstruction is that it's
self-supervised so we can detect
immediately that we have a problem
so the principle of this i call it an
anomaly detection through failure
is to try to create a task in which the
learned system should fail
outside of the training data so we don't
want it to generalize at all
a challenge with auto encoders these
days with deep learning is that they can
be too good they can actually learn to
be very good image compression systems
and so they work well on all images
including ones outside the training data
set
okay uh i think i already said all of
this
i guess another weakness is that
it's not obvious that using say a
squared pixel level reconstruction error
is the right thing to use um
because it really doesn't capture the
semantics of the image similarity and
people also find that training these is
difficult although variational
autoencoders have made it easier it's
still quite hard and as i say it's hard
to prevent an autoencoder from becoming
a general image compression algorithm
okay well now let's move on to deep
anomaly detection for classifiers
so um the the you know beauty of deep
learning is that we learn a
representation um
instead of having to hand engineer it
um but uh
let's say it man but it's it's a
representation that is really sufficient
for the particular task that we're
training it to perform so in this in
case of classification this means the
representation is good at separating the
label training data by class but it
doesn't necessarily provide a good
representation for detecting anomalies
and so uh let's let's look at four
different representational learning
approaches that have been used in trying
to do deep anomaly detection
the first is just training a supervised
classifier so we could use a standard
thing like uh like this uh simple cnn
um
and of course uh we treat the backbone
as an encoder that produces a latent
representation and from there there's a
fully connected network that produces
the logits and those go into a softmax
to give us our probabilities
so uh the idea for an anomaly score
would be to um to use the uh
the for instance the maximum of these
logits or the the uh
the confidence which is one minus the
maximum of the predicted probabilities
to use that as our anomaly score my
student alex guyer has been doing a
study to try to understand what is
happening in the representation during
supervised classification
so what he did was to take a dense net
and train it on six known classes from
the cfar10 image dataset holding out
four novel classes to be our anomaly
classes and then he took all the
intermediate all the latent activations
throughout the entire training process
and did one big umap visualization of
them so we can see here in the in the
before uh learning begins
uh the images have all been mapped to
just a few number of locations a small
number of locations here in the latent
space so these light green points are
the anomaly classes and each of the the
known classes has a different darker
shade of green
and so now we'll space through
the epics and you can see that points
are being pulled out from the center
to form these kind of chains that then
coalesce into
clusters and this is the the sort of
final arrangement of the of the learning
and we can see that uh
that each of the six known classes has
formed up a pretty nice cluster maybe
it's a little spread out in some cases
um but the unfortunate thing is that the
four unknown classes have not formed up
any any recognizable cluster structure
instead they they're still mostly
occupying the sort of center of the
space although some of them have been
pulled out and are must must be confused
with with points that belong to these
classes
so
so from a distance function a distance
metric learning perspective doing
supervised classification with softmax
as our loss function
is uh is giving us uh good distances
within and between clusters of the
training classes exactly as we would
expect but it's not so good at giving us
distance measures between the anomalies
uh and uh and other anomalies
and also between the anomalies and the
known classes
so um
when we when we trained up a classifier
we generally use one of these three
anomaly scores either the entropy of the
projective probabilities or one minus
the maximum of the predicted
probabilities which we could think of as
a kind of uh one
one minus the confidence
or the negative of the maximum logit
before it goes through the softmax
we find this is actually the best of the
of these measures but they all perform
quite similarly
so my student rishi garupali uh did a
headroom analysis
asking how well do existing anomaly
scoring methods extract the anomaly
information that is captured in the
latent representation of the learned
network
and our approach was to compare that to
an oracle anomaly detector that was
trained using labeled anomalies on with
that representation
and then the second question was how
well could any network with this
architecture perform
and to do that we would train say on all
10 c4 classes and then see how well the
anomaly score uh could compute the the
anomalous
classes so we did this on c410 with the
sixth known and four unknown split or a
cfr 100 with an 80 known and 20 uh
unknown split
we're using auc as our main measure and
uh resin at 34 as the backbone
um the results are shown here
uh so we can see uh here's the cfar
results right so this is just the basic
uh supervised training followed by uh
using say the max logic is our anomaly
score and we're getting aucs in the 0.77
range
if we use the same trained
representation but now use a supervised
classifier in this case a thousand tree
random forest that's given labeled
anomalies and nominals it can get up to
about
0.905 so gaining about 13 auc points uh
just by using a better a more informed
anomaly scoring method
and if we train a classifier on
all 10 classes uh and then ask how well
it can do it can get up to what point uh
uh nine eight seven
um
so uh so the the lesson there is that
the latent space contains much more
anomaly information than than is
extractable using current anomaly scores
and probably that is extractable even by
a linear uh uh
anomaly detector
um and uh
and and furthermore there is additional
headroom particularly when there's a
small number of training classes
one thing is that when you have a large
number of training classes of course the
problem itself gets harder but the but
the amount of headroom and the gaps are
are smaller
so we have eight uh uh auc points um
uh if we just use an oracle anomaly
detector and uh and we get an additional
two points if we can get a better
representation
so the there's a lot of so surprisingly
these latent representations learned
during classification are quite good uh
perhaps not as good as we would like
them to be but but a lot better than we
than they seem to be performing using
our current anomaly scores
so are there ways we can extract
improved anomaly scores by doing for
instance for example density estimation
so one thing you can do is fit a
multivariate gauss into each of the
known classes and use that as a mixture
model for the probability density of the
of all the known classes and then score
the surprisal uh
uh of the of the green points basically
to uh to ask uh you know do they allow
outside this or not and this is very
practical and works surprisingly well
there are some tricks because of course
this is a uh
say in this case a 384 dimensional
gaussian so
the coherence matrix may not be quite a
full rank so there are some tricks you
need to do but it's doable
and there was a nice paper uh from lily
lee and shin 2018
where they showed
they fit uh what they call the
mahalanobis distance method which is
they fit a single covariance matrix
across all of the classes um and then
they're able to use that since that's
now constant they can just compute the
mahalanobis distance between the z value
of the query point and the means of each
of the classes and and take the nearest
class distance to the nearest class as
our anomaly score
and they get uh significant improvements
in performance on auc
big improvements on the true negative
rate give at 95 percent true positive
rate so detecting 95 percent of the of
the anomalies and uh and and uh just raw
classification accuracy actually
increases as well
so um i have a white live warning here
because the paper includes several other
improvements i just wanted this sort of
clean case of fitting the
mahalanobis distance here
another technique that's been applied is
to
replace the softmax output with uh
or the the training target with some
change
uh in the hopes that this helps us learn
an improved representation
so uh there's been work on label
smoothing on something called geodin and
something called isomax i and let me
talk about each of those
so label smoothing is an old idea from
the 1990s that was reintroduced in the
deep learning context by uh ziggety in
2015
and the idea is to use the standard
softmax output layer but instead of
using the usual one hot targets which is
all zeros except for one a one one for
the target class
we instead are going to sort of steal
probability mass alpha from that class
and spread it uniformly across all the
other classes so now the other classes
are trying to hit a target of alpha over
k
for the incorrect answer and one minus
alpha plus alpha over k for the correct
answer and a paper coming out of the
toronto by mueller at all
shows that this causes the data points
to form tighter clusters
than we get if we use the one hot
targets
and so with those tighter clusters now
it
it makes sense that we could fit better
gaussians to them and perhaps improve
our anomaly scoring
another idea that came out of the odin
and then later this generalized odin or
geode method
from last year
is to compute the logit as the ratio of
two learned functions
so the the logic
activation for class k
is going to be h sub k of z divided by
g of z
and h k is a class specific uh
sort of strength function and g of z is
a is a
instant specific uh normalizer and then
they apply the softmax on top of this
and surprisingly although we haven't
done a representational analysis of this
but we see experimentally that we're
getting
significant improvements in auc
especially on c5 100 using this
technique and we've also seen nice
improvements on imagenet 100
and the most recent one is from this
year's isomax i by mercedo and ludamir
they learn a prototype for each class k
in the latent space so instead of
fitting the mean of the latent space
points they learn a prototype point
and then they um they normalize the
prototypes and the z values by their
norms so that they're now lying on a
sphere and then they calculate the logic
for class k
as a
as a
parameter kappa that they set a learned
scaling parameter c and then the
distance euclidean distance measured in
that normalized space
and uh and they again saw big
improvements in auc
um
and uh i believe this was also on c410
and uh and improvements in the true
negative rate while controlling uh uh by
by achieving a true positive rate of 95
so very nice uh performance there
and there have been several other
proposals right for putting the gaussian
process as the final layer a deer slate
distribution instead of a categorical
distribution
and and i think the open research
question here is we need to compare the
learned representations of these
different methods to see how they're
doing
the third method has been approached in
the deep learning community is hybrid
methods so the idea was to combine a
supervised loss with an anomaly
detection method either supervised plus
an autoencoder or supervised plus a deep
density estimator
and so you have something that looks
like this where you have a say a resnet
34 backbone then you have the standard
softmax classification head and but then
also a decoder to a reconstruction head
and then you somehow balance the losses
of these two errors with some magic
parameter lambda and uh and then see how
well this works and in and there are
similar ideas that have been uh
implemented by by other teams in our
work uh again by my student rishikali
um we uh we found that we used very
different values of lambda and in this
case we cheated and uh we're finding the
lambda that gave the best performance
because again we were kind of interested
in in a head room analysis
so um what we found was that this hybrid
representation can really improve
performance um
so so very little improvement with the
raw anomaly detector but the oracle can
do much better so somehow we are
learning a better representation
and uh and slightly better on the oracle
classifier
and those carry over to c4 100 as well
so uh another uh example is uh is a
hybrid network in which they're
combining a classifier with the standard
cross-entropy loss with a flow-based
density model now we're calculating they
write this as log p of x but it's really
log p of z where z is the um uh the
latent representation right because uh
this is we're starting with the latent
representation here which is a much more
sensible idea
um and so they are training
uh this um uh
using uh i think they were using glow
another one of the flow-based methods
and uh and and they they also got good
performance um
there are uh other techniques that have
been applied in a similar way
um
but their results for open hybrid um
uh they they were only reporting for auc
but they but they saw substantial then
they were in the out of distribution uh
no no they're they're in the open
category set up um they're they're doing
uh quite well on on these as well
okay and the the final method i want to
talk about is instance contrastive
learning uh of the type that was uh
made popular by sinclair um the idea
here is that you we're going to do
unsupervised training of the learning of
the representation
um right and we start with a set of
image transformations such as rotation
scalings clippings uh changes to the
color map um
uh adding salt and pepper noise you know
various kinds of transformations like
that
and uh and there are two two cases in
case one we we're work uh we input the
same image and we send it through the
backbone twice once after being
transformed by transformation one which
is sampled
you know at random from the set uh big t
of transformations and the second time
with a different transformation and they
go through the backbone and we get the
latent representations z1 and z2 and
then they're sent through a projection
network which is a just a multi-layer
perceptron down to a lower dimensional
space
and in this space we apply cosine
similarity as our laws and and in this
case because it's the same image
transformed two different ways we want
to back propagate to change the uh the
weights in order to make these two
representations more similar
and of course by making u1 and u2 more
similar this will also act to make z1
and z2 more similar in in a relevant way
um
whereas if we take two different images
x1 and x2 and apply two transformations
uh one to each each of them push them
through now we want to um decrease the
cosine similarity between these two uh
nodes
and you may ask why do we have this
projection network
i think the idea was uh that the cosine
similarity works better in a lower
dimensional space but also um
this kind of
mutes a bit the impact of the cosine
similarity on the latent representation
now we still retain uh much higher
dimensional information the latent
representation and that may be useful
both for classification and for anomaly
detection by doing that
so uh uh what the simclear team showed
was that if they use
large networks and train for a long time
like 900 epics of this kind of uh
self-supervised training and then learn
a linear uh linear logits on top of it
with a relatively modest amount of
supervised data they can match the
performance of state-of-the-art
supervised classifiers on the top one
accuracy for imagenet
so this is exciting um it's very
expensive and so from my perspective
it's it's interesting primarily because
it works at all
not because it's the right way to do
imagenet um but of course the the claim
is that it may be the right way to learn
representations when we don't have
labeled data
well um if there was a paper by attack
at all uh that used a
single a variation on sinclair to try to
um do anomaly detection
and uh and they did a teasing
visualization of the final state of the
learned representation and they found
much the same phenomena that we saw
earlier which is that this was for uh
out of distribution uh evaluation so the
in the known classes were all from c410
and the outer distribution points were
drawn from c4 100
but the supervised learning or
unsupervised learning have been done
self-supervised learning had been done
on c410
and we can see that uh again
the novel points are lying toward the
center of the space whereas the ones we
trained on are scattered out a lot more
so
a nice piece of work that came out of
google by winkins at all uh applied then
multivariate gaussian scoring on top of
sinclair
and they used they combined both sim
clear and soft max with label smoothing
and they found that they got much better
um
uh uh auc's for the uh for the out of
distribution uh uh c410 to cfr 100.
um
they also measured uh uh the effect of
of of using their architecture but with
no contrastive training so only
supervised and with no label smoothing
and show that both of those made a big
difference and they also looked at
controlling the the true positive rate
and and so they could really drop their
false positive rate uh quite a lot
although 40 false positives is still uh
a pretty big number
okay well um so i guess the the main
lesson to take home from this discussion
of deep anomaly detection is that we
don't have uh mature methods here
uh
that we also find that supervised
training is is surprisingly good or just
by itself
but maybe these hybrid methods that
combine a supervised head and some
second task a self-supervised task or
against the estimation task
seem to give us some additional benefit
and for a purely self-supervised
approach i'd say
the jury is still out as to whether
that's going to be competitive
with these other methods especially i
think the challenge is when the number
of classes gets very large
it seems that a lot of the
tricks and techniques that the field has
been exploring maybe they don't pay off
as much and maybe a fairly
straightforward approach when you're
training a classifier on 500 categories
of objects you're probably learning a
pretty good representation
and so we need to be studying that as
well
okay well the final question i wanted to
discuss is uh how can we set our anomaly
detection threshold in all the work
we've been doing here we've either been
uh uh just set uh computing auc which
avoids the threshold or we've been
optimizing the threshold to to measure
say the true positive rate
or the false alarm rate at that given
operating point
but how can we set it
well if we want to maximize our true
alarm rate or true detection rate true
positive rate at a 5 false alarm rate so
we want to just control false alarms
then it's fairly straightforward what we
want to do is look at this black curve
here
this is a
kernel density estimator showing the
anomaly scores
on our known classes right so this is
probability density this is the anomaly
score and if we want to have a 5 false
alarm rate we want to set our threshold
tau here such that the area under this
black curve is five percent
and then because that's where those will
be our false alarms
and then our true alarms right will be
the just what's under the blue curve the
blue curve
are the anomaly scores on our uh on our
anomaly points which we don't have we
don't know that blue curve right at the
time we have to choose tau
unless we have a representative sample
of labeled anomalies uh then we can then
we can measure that blue curve but in
general we don't have it at least
initially
um but if we want to do uh the if we're
more in the ai safety setting where we
want to um
say correctly classify detect 95 percent
of these anomalies or novel class
objects then we need to set our
threshold here based on the the blue
curve such that there's say only five
percent of the areas under this left
tail
and to do that we need to somehow
estimate the blue curve
well if we don't have any data points
what can we do
well one possibility is we might have
access to unlabeled data that is
contaminated so let's say that we have a
training sample s naught of d of clean
data from the nominal distribution
and then we have an unlabeled sample s m
which is a mixture
with uh
probability fraction 1 minus alpha are
coming from the nominal distribution and
some fractions some proportion alpha are
anomalies so we're saying we have alpha
percent contamination in this mixture
okay and we'll come back to how we might
know what alpha is but uh but uh if we
assume we know alpha
then um if we could compute the um
the cumulative distribution function of
the anomaly scores for the anomalies
uh it would look like this then we could
set our threshold tau here to get you
know five percent uh the the five
percent quantile uh of of this uh cdf
instead of the pdf uh
um and so that's what we would like to
do
but of course we don't have the cdf for
the anomaly scores either
but uh but the if the if the uh
densities are our mixture then the
the cdfs are also a mixture
and if the cdf's are mixture then we can
do some little algebra here and we can
solve for the anomaly cdf
by subtracting
the
the mixture and the nominal and dividing
by alpha
so ideally we'd have a picture that
looks like this we estimate f naught and
fm from our two samples s naught and s m
plug them in here and we get out f a
reality unfortunately looks like this at
least for a small sample i chose a
particularly bad looking one but we can
see that our empirical cdfs for for the
anomaly scores for f naught and for fm
are beautiful you know uh empirical cdfs
they're step functions but they but
they're monotonically increasing they
start at zero they end at one
but the but when we subtract them we get
a mess right this is not increasing
monotonically it goes negative it does
start at zero and end at one
but uh but what can we do
um well what we're going to use is
actually
if we're interested in like the the five
percentile here
we will use the rightmost crossing of
this to set our threshold tau because
that's the safe choice
fortunately the real
case looks a bit like this although if
you zoom in you still might have
multiple crossings here but we're going
to use the right most edge
and then we can prove a theorem
in the pac style that says um if we have
this amount of training data then with
probability one minus delta we will have
an alien detection rate of at least one
minus q plus epsilon so epsilon is our
kind of error approximation parameter
and it enters here as a one over epsilon
squared which is the typical thing you
see in uh these kind of concentration
bound based methods
um and alpha also appears here it
basically is one over alpha squared so
as alpha gets tiny and his epsilon gets
tiny our required sample size gets very
large
and this makes sense because when alpha
is very small we actually have very few
anomalies in that mixture distribution
so the sample size needs to get big
enough so that we can actually get
enough anomalies
uh effectively to to measure uh fa
so it uh what about estimating alpha how
can we figure out what alpha is well uh
from a strict uh point of view it is not
identifiable in general
but under reasonable assumptions we can
obtain a pretty good estimate and this
was an experiment where we compared uh
uh five different estimates from the
literature with the ground truth so the
the truth is this uh pink line here and
we can see that this orange line here
which is uh from a paper by patra and
send 2016
is giving a quite decent performance
doesn't do too well in this one letter
recognition data set but it's doing
quite well on the others
so uh my students see you led this work
along with rasheed garpali divashis
mandal and myself and uh and we have a
paper under review
let me wrap up this entire presentation
by reviewing what i covered so first we
talked about the sort of main families
of anomaly detection methods
distance based methods density methods
density quantile estimation and then
reconstruction error
and then we switched and looked at
deep learning from the point of view of
learning a good representation in which
we could use distance or density
estimation or density quantile
estimation
or possibly reconstruction
and uh and we compared basically we
showed the supervised classification
with softmax is already not terrible uh
although there is a lot of headroom for
extracting the anomaly score
better than than just using the logits
we saw that you can gain some
improvements by changing the final layer
to to not be just the standard softmax
we saw that we could also gain
improvements by using a hybrid a
two-headed network where we combine
supervised classification with one of
these anomaly detection losses say
density estimation or distances or
reconstruction
and then the most speculative technique
is instance contrastive learning and uh
and we show that it while it shows some
promise it also appears to show the same
weaknesses as supervised classification
in that the uh anomaly points uh are not
given distinct representations uh at
least compared to the to the nominal
points
so i think there are many open research
questions here this is not by any means
a finished topic
we really need to understand what's
going on in representation learning can
we come up with improved methods that
give us representations that represent
a a space that is uh that goes beyond
just our training data can we
extrapolate the representation
um and then we need methods for
comparing these learned representations
to study them and and uh and i and it
would be particularly wonderful if we
could have an open framework where we
could do control the comparisons of
these methods because as you can see
i couldn't build you just one table
showing the comparison of all these
methods because everyone is using
different setups
and and some are using the ood setting
some are using the uh the open category
setting
and if we can get all that working there
are still many other questions for
instance how can we explain the
anomalies we find to users
or to subject matter experts we said
well this case looks weird figure you
figure out why we want to say here's why
we think it's unusual
and if we can get feedback from users uh
in previous work at oregon state um
by amran siddiki
he showed in his thesis that
incorporating user feedback in online
into the anomaly detection procedure can
be extremely powerful in improving our
true positive rates
and reducing our false alarm rates
and of course if we are discovering new
categories we should be learning
definitions for them say with few shot
learning and incorporating them into the
classifier but few shot learning has
basically the same representational
needs as anomaly detection these new
points should should be meaningfully
separated from the previously known
classes
well i'll stop here and conclude in the
slides i have uh the bibliography for
all the things that i cited here
and i'm eager to uh to hear your
reactions
you can reach me on twitter as at
tdtrick or my email is tgd.cs.orst.edu